le corbeau et le renard maître corbeau
sur un arbre perché tenait en son bec un
fromage un pignouf de korbach sur un
arbre planté pincer dans la fiole un
coup l'embardée
c'est le fromage ça
maître renard par l'odeur alléché 80 à
peu près ce langage des corbeaux que
vous êtes jolie que vous me semblez
si votre ramage se rapporte à votre
plumage vous êtes le phénix des hôtes de
ces bois
les hôtes de ces bois
[Musique]
à
1 0
le corps ne se sent plus de joie et prom
monte et pour montrer sa belle voix
faites moi qu'il faut pas le voir
l'attendaient à 3 le renard s'ensuivit
et bi mon bon monsieur
apprenez que tout flatteur vit au dépend
de celui qui l'écouté
[Musique]
le corbeau ou peu répond fut jura mais
un peu tard qu'on ne l'y prendrait plus
grand cauchemar